السعوديه وامريكا تعلنني توقيعات طرفي
الصراع في السودان اتفاقيه لوقف اطلاق
النار قصير الامد
السعوديه تجدد حرصها على امن واستقرار
السودان وسط ترحيب باتفاق وقت اطلاق النار
الكريم يعلن بسط السيطره على بعد
تؤكد استمرار المعارك في المدينه
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
هذه النشره تاتيكم من قناه العربيه
والبدايه من ازمه السودان حيث قالت
السعوديه والولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
بيان مشترك ان طرفي الصراع في السودان
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع وقع
على اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار لمده سبعه
ايام وجاء في البيان المشترك ان وقفه
اطلاق النار سيدخل حيز التنفيذ بعد 48
ساعه من التوقيع ويمكن تمديده بموافقه
الطرفين واضاف البيان ان الجانبين اتفقا
على ايصال وتوزيع المساعدات الانسانيه
واستعاده الخدمات الاساسيه وسحب القوات من
المستشفيات والمرافق العامه الاساسيه كما
اتفق الطرفان على تسهيل المرور الامن
لمقدمين مساعدات الانسانيه مما يسمح بتدفق
المساعدات دون عوائق من موانئ الدخول الى
السكان المحتاجين واضاف البيان انه خلافا
للاتفاقات فان الاتفاق جديد الذي تم
التوصل اليه في مدينه جده السعوديه ستدعمه
اليه مراقبه وقف اطلاق النار المدعومه
دوليا من قبل المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لا يخفى عليكم
العربيه السعوديه وخادم الحرمين والعهد
على السودان وعلى استقرار السودان وعلى
امن السودان
ونسال الله ان شاء الله ان يرفع هذه الغمه
على السودان وعن اهلها ان شاء الله
والحقيقه شاكرين على موقفكم هذا اليوم
وعلى تعاونكم في الوصول الى هذا الاتفاق
واهل السودان منتظرين هذا وهذا ان شاء
الله في خير كثير يعني تعرفون انه الدم
هذا غالي والدم السوداني غالي وانتم تغذون
اكثر يعني اكثر من اي احد ان شاء الله هذا
الاتفاق سيكون بصيص امل لاهل السودان
بالذات اهل الخرطوم في انه يعني يستطيعون
ان يعالجون امورهم الانسانيه في هذه وان
شاء الله ترتدي لاكثر وان شاء الله خطوه
في الطريق الصحيحه بارك الله فيكم وشكرا
لكم على تجاوبكم وشكرا على موقفكم هذا وان
شاء الله يعني ما نرى من بعد هذا الا كل
الخير للسودان واهل السودان ان شاء الله
هذا هو رحبت قوى الحريه والتغيير في
السودان باتفاق وقت اطلاق النار الذي تم
توقيعه بين الطرفي الصراع في السودان ودعت
قوى الحريه والتغيير في بيان الى الالتزام
الكامل باعلان مبادئ جده وباتفاق وقت
اطلاق النار قصير الامد والترتيبات
الانسانيه
واعربت عن الامل بان يشكل هذا الاتفاق
خطوه اخرى الى الامام في طريق الوقف الكلي
لهذه الحرب من جانبه وصف رئيس حزب المؤتمر
السوداني عمر الديار توقيع الاتفاق بخطوه
ايجابيه اخرى في معالجه الكارثه الانسانيه
في السودان وشكر حزب المؤتمر السوداني
المملكه العربيه السعوديه والولايات
المتحده لتسيير الوصول لهذه الخطوه المهمه
مناشدا المجتمع الدولي والاقليمي وصلت
استنفار الجهود وتنسيقها لتقديم المساعدات
الانسانيه
وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه عن ادانتها
واستنكارها لاقتحام وتخريب السفاره
القطريه في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
واكدت الخارجيه السعوديه رفض المملكه
التامه لكل اشكال العنف والتخريب تجاه
البعثات والممثلات الدبلوماسيه وطالبت
الخارجيه السعوديه كافه الاطراف السودانيه
بالالتزام بالتهدئه وفق نتائج مباحثات جده
الاخيره والانخراط في المسار السياسي الذي
يسعى للوصول الى حل عادلا وشامل للازمه في
السودان
قال ياسر العطا مساعد قائد الجيش السوداني
عبد الفتاح البرهان في لقاء مع التلفزيون
السوداني انه تم القضاء على اكثر من 85%
من قوه قوه ما وصفه بالتمرد الموجوده في
البلاد مشيرا الى ان ما يحدث في البلاد
حرب ولها تبعاتها ودع ياسر العطاء مساعد
قائد الجيش السوداني المواطنين السودانيين
الى التحلي بالصبر معتبرا ان الحل قريب
واضاف ان الموقف الان لا يتطلب التسليح
المواطنين لكن من يتسلح فليتسلح لحمايه
نفسه وهذا من حقه على حد تعبيره
الصراع في السودان في شهره الثاني خريطه
المواجهه تتسع وتتسع معها معاناه
السودانيين مقاتله الجيش شنت هجمات على
ضواحي العاصمه الخرطوم وجنوبي ام درمان
اضافه الى شمالي الخرطوم بحري ووقعت
اشتباكات ايضا في منطقه شارع النيل وسط
الخرطوم وفي اقليم دارفور كانت مدينه
نيالا عاصمه ولايه جنوب دارفور مسرحا
لمواجهه عسكريه ومعارك داميه في المدينه
حيث اندلع قتال بري هناك قوه الجيش اعلنت
سيطرتها على المدينه بعد اشتباكات مع قوات
الدعم السريع واستهداف حاميه النيال
العسكريه كما شهدت مدينه زلنجي في ولايه
وسط دارفور اشتباكات مسلحه بين قوات الدعم
السريع والجيش وبينما يدخل الصراع اسبوعه
السادس تحصي البلاد قتلاها فبحسب نقابه
الاطباء السودانيين تجاوز عدد القتل 850
شخصا مدنيا
فيما اصيب اكثر من
4390 شخصا حصيله الضحايا قد تكون اعلى
بكثير وفق اطباء خصوصا في ظل صعوبه الوصول
الى جميع المستشفيات تحديدا خارج العاصمه
لحصر جميع الوفيات او الاصابات بدقه
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان القوات
الروسيه بسطت سيطرتها الكامله على مدينه
بخموت شرق اوكرانيا وهنا الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين قوات التي كانت اعلنت
اكمال السيطره على المدينه واعلن الكرملين
انه سيقوم بتكريم جميع من تميزوا في معارك
باخموت في المقابل اكد الجانب الاوكراني
استمرار المعارك وان القوات الاوكرانيه ما
زالت تخوض المعارك هناك
معركه باخمه حسمت لمصلحه باجنر
في اغسطس عام 2022 بدات روسيا هجومها
الرئيسي على بخموت
وفي اكتوبر الماضي اصبحت بخمت محورا
اساسيا للحرب
في ذات الشهر دخلت مجموعه فاجنان كقوه
رئيسيه في المعركه
اما في نوفمبر الماضي صعدت مجموعه فاقنر
هجماتها بدعم الجيش الروسي
[موسيقى]
فبراير هذا العام فيغنر سيطرت على المحاور
الشرقيه والجنوبيه
واليوم تعلن باجنر السيطره الكامله على
معركه دامت اكثر من تسعه اشهر
[موسيقى]
مع وعودي دول الناتو بارسال المزيد من
الذخيره لدعم اوكرانيا في حربها ضد روسيا
تعتبر امريكا الى حد ما اكبر متبرع
بالمساعدات العسكريه لكياب كما وعدت
الولايات المتحده وحلفاء اخرون ام في حلف
الناتو بتوفير طائرات مقاتله متطوره
لاوكرانيا ودعم تدريب الطيارين
الاوكرانيين على قيادتها
التعهدات الغربيه بارسال مساعدات عسكريه
لاوكرانيا مستمره اخرها دول حلف الناتو
التي وعدت بارسال المزيد من الذخيره لدعم
اوكرانيا باستعاده اراضيها من الروس
ما هي اكثر الدول المانحه للمساعدات
العسكريه لاوكرانيا امريكا سته
واربعون.6 مليار دولار بريطانيا
5.1 مليار دولار الاتحاد الاوروبي
3.3 مليار دولار بولندا 2.5 مليار دولار
المانيا
2.5 مليار دولار كندا
1.4 مليار دولار اما عن انواع المعدات
العسكريه المقدمه من الدول المانحه
لاوكرانيا فهي عباره عن 31 دبابه ابرامز
مقدمه من امريكا والتي وصفها الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن بانها اكثر الدبابات
قدره في العالم ونظام صواريخ المدفعيه
عاليه الحركه هاي مارس 59 مركبه قتاليه من
طراز برادلي وانظمه للدفاع الجوي بالاضافه
الى مدافع اما بريطانيا فقدمت لاوكر انيا
اربع عشره دبابه تشالنجر 2 وانظمه الدفاع
جوي تتضمن ستار ستريك والمانيا في المقابل
اعطت كيف اربع عشره دبابه ليوبار 2 وانظمه
الدفاع جوي تتضمن ايرستي واخيرا بولندا
اكثر من 200 دبابه لاوكرانيا
رئيس البرلمان اللي بيع عقيله صالح رفضه
لاشراف حكومه الدبيبه او غيرها في اشاره
الى حكومه بشاغه على الانتخابات مشيرا في
تصريحات للعربيه الى ان مجلس الدوله
الاعلى والبرلمان سيتفقان على حكومه مصغره
تشرف على اجراء الانتخابات
القانون نحن نحتاج فعلا الى انتخاباتنا ان
تكون قبل نهايه السنه
اذا نريد حكومه تشغل على الانتخابات
بالتكييف سيكون هناك اتفاق بالمجلس الدوله
عندما يتفق مجلس النواب ومجلس الدوله على
تشكيل الحكومه يجب ان تكون الى الحكومه
الشرعيه
نحن نحن لا نعترض على على ترشحات كما قلت
وانا مصر ان من يستبعد او يقرب هو صندوق
الاقتراب لما يصح لاي مجموعه الاشخاص شعب
الليبي هو من يقول من يحكم عن طريق صناديق
الاقتراح اما بالنسبه للدبي نحن لا نرفض
ترشح لكن لا يقبل ان نترشح وهو رئيس
الدوله الاستراتينيه بيده الاموال
والاجهزه الامنيه والكتابيه والاداريه
اعتقد انها تختل العداله ولم نكن هناك
هناك مساواه
نشرتنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
ناخبون الاتراك في الخارج يبداون التصويت
في جوله الاعاده للانتخابات الرئاسيه
اهلا بكم من جديد بدا الناخبون الاتراك في
الخارج التصويت في جوله الاعاده
للانتخابات الرئاسيه والتي ستنطلق في 28
من مايو الجاري ومن المنتظر تصويت الاتراك
في الممثليات التركيه خلال الفتره من
العشرين الى الرابع والعشرين من مايو وعلى
ان يستمر التصويت في المعابر الحدوديه
والمطارات حتى الثامن والعشرين من مايو
مشاركه يبدو انها كبيره في صور هي الاولى
لانتخابات الاتراك في الخارج طوابير
الناخبين التي تنتظر التصويت في البعثات
التركيه خارج البلاد تنبا بمنافسه حاده في
جوله الاعاده بين الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
وزعيم المعارضه كمال كلجدار اوغلو اردوغان
الذي تقدم على منافسه بنحو مليونين ونصف
المليون صوت في الجوله الاولى اختار مناطق
الزلزال المنكوبه لبدء جولته الانتخابيه
وانتقد من هناك خصمه
نرى ان رئيسها حزب الشعب الجمهوري الذي
هزم في انتخابات الرابع عشر من مايو وفقد
الامل في 28 من مايو يستخدم لغه سامه
وقبيحه اكثر فاكثر انه يحول جزءا من
مجتمعنا الى عدو بتصريحاته المتهوره والتي
تحض على الكراهيه هي فرصه اردوغان للطعن
بخصمه كالجدار اوغلو زعيم حزب الشعب
الجمهوري بعد ردود فعل عنيفه من انصار
مرشح المعارضه ضد سكان الولايات التي
ضربها الزلزال بسبب تصويطهم لاردوكان على
وقع هذه التطورات قرر معسكر المعارضه
تصعيد لهجته بشكل كبير ضد اللاجئين بهدف
جذب اصوات القوميين من مؤيدين مرشح
الرئاسي سنان اوغان
سوريا
انتخابات الجوله الثانيه هي اختيار بين من
يتجنبون ترحيل السوريين ومن يخطط لترحيلهم
خلال عامين المعارضه تعتمد في خطابها ايضا
على الربط بين حزب الدعوه الحره او هدى
بار الداعم لاردوغان بحزب الله التركي وما
نفذه الحزب من اعمال تصنفها تركيا
بالارهابيه ورئيس اردوغان خلال الايام
الاخيره الماضيه هو يركز بشكل كبير على
شريحه الشباب بعد التصويت له في الجوله
الاولى في المقابل كريستيانو يحاول اللعب
على وتر القوميه من خلال معاداه اللاجئين
والهدف الاساسي هو كسب اصوات سنان اوغان
قبل اسبوع من جوله الاعاده ستلجا المعارضه
الى خطاب متطرف اكثر تجاه اللاجئين دون ان
تنسى العامل الاقتصادي الذي يراهن عليه
زعيم المعارضه خصوصا في المدن الكبرى
ذو مهمه زعيم المعارضه اصعب في اقناع
مزيدا من الناخبين بالتصويت له في الجوله
الثانيه خصوصا في ظل حيازه اردوغان
الاغلبيه بالبرلمان وخشيه الناخب من
التعارض بين السلطتين التنفيذيه
والتشريعيه فهل ستنجح خطابات المعارضه
المتشدده في تغيير مزاج ناخب ام ان خيار
الاستقرار والتوافق بين البرلمان والرئاسه
سيكون عاملا حاسما زيدان زنجلو العربيه
اسطنبول
عربه الصين عن استيائها الشديد اذا بياني
مجموعه الدول السبع الكبرى بعد اجتماع
قاده اجتماعي قادته في هيروشيما وقالت
الخارجيه الصينيه في بيان انها تدين
محاولات مجموعه السبعه لتشويه سمعه الصين
الدوليه واشارت الى ان مجموعه السبع مصره
على التلاعب بقضايا ذات اولويه بالنسبه
لبكين واتهمت الخارجيه الصينيه مجموعه
السبع بتعطيل السلام العالمي وكبح تنميه
الدول الاخرى وانها تقدمت باحتجاجا رسميا
الى اليابان التي استضافت القمه ضد
مخرجاتها
على مقربه من بكين ترمي دول مجموعه السبع
حبال الوصل طاره وتشدها طاره كما تقول دول
المجتمعه في هيروشيما اليابانيه تريد بناء
علاقات مستقره مع الصين لكنها تعارض السعي
الصيني لعسكره اسيا والمحيط الهادئ بكين
كانت استبقت البياض الختاميه للمجموعه
بوعيد على لسان السفاراتها في لندن
باجراءات قويه وحازمه ليس فقط ازاء
الافعال وانما الاقوال ايضا
البيان الختامي لدول السبع اكد على ضروره
حل المشاكل الاقليميه السلميه واحترام
السياده الدول كما اكد على موقف المجموعه
من مبدا الصين واحده موقف مصحوب برفض
للمحاولات الاحاديه لتغيير الوضع القائم
بالقوه والاكراه اضافه الى رفض مطالب بكين
التوسعيه في بحر الصين الجنوبي
بينما يريد قاده المجموعه التمكين
للعلاقات الاقتصاديه مع الصين سيواجهون
سياساتها غير القائمه على السوق اضافه
لمواجهه ممارسه الصين على غرار النقل غير
المشروع للتكنولوجيا وتعزيز القدرات على
مواجهه الاكراه الاقتصادي
عدد مجموعه السبع من الصين الضغط على
روسيا لوقف حملتها العسكريه في اوكرانيا
وسحب قواتها بشكل فوري وشامل وبدون شروط
من اوكرانيا وفقا لميثاق الامم المتحده
ومن خلال حوار مباشر مع اوكرانيا
وبين شد وجذب وتقرب وانتقاد تقول بكين
انما يقال ويعمل عليه افتراء وتشويه سمعه
والرد سيكون حاضرا
اتهم محامي مالك موقع تويتر ايلون ماسك
اليكس بايرو شركه مايكروسوفت في رساله
باساءه استخدام بيانات الخدمه وطالب
بالتدقيق من قبل شركه البرمجيات العملاقه
[موسيقى]
مواجهه وشيكا ساحتها رقميه واسلحتها
خوارزميات هائله تلك هي الحروب العصريه
التي يصبح اغلى ما فيها المعلومات المشفره
انها المعركه القادمه بين عصفور ازرق يدعى
تويتر وشركه البرمجيه العملاقه مايكروسوفت
فتيلها اشتعل منذ ان غرد الملياردير
الامريكي ايلون ماسك قائلا انهم يستخدمون
بيانات تويتر بشكل غير قانوني وحان وقت
رفع الدعوه القضائيه وفي رساله تحذيريه
حملت ادعاءات غامضه وجهها اليكسسبيرو
محامي ملك تويتر الى الساتيا ناديلا
الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه مايكروسوفت تتمحور
حول تجاوز حجم الطلب المعقول لبيانات
تويتر بل حتى استخدامها بافراط واساءه
مضيفا ان الاتفاقيه التي عقدت بينهما
لتشرع هذا الكم الهائل من الاستخدام علما
بانهم استرجعوا اكثر من 26 مليار تغريده
في عام 2022 وحده هذا عدا عن ان الاتفاقيه
بينهما نصت على انه لا يحق لميكروسوفت
استرداد ايا من بيانات تويتر لاي كيان او
وكاله دون اختارهم مطالبا بالتدقيق المفصل
والممل للبيانات التي اخذتها من تويتر او
دمرتها ولاي تطبيق قدمتها ولماذا في
المقابل اكتفى المتحدث باسم مايكروسوفت
فرانكشو بان الشركه ستاخذ بالاعتبار اسئله
وطلبات تويتر
وسترد عليها بالشكل المناسب مؤكدا انهم
يتطلعون الى شراكه طويله الامد اسراء
الصغير العربيه
ادت الفيضانات وشمال شرقي ايطاليا الى
نزوح اكثر من 36 الف شخص مسؤولين ايطاليين
حيث ابتلعت المياه مرتفعه المنسوب المزيد
من المنازل في المنطقه كما عزلت
الانهيارات الارضيه القرى الصغيره عن
المدن
[موسيقى]
تشارك السينما العربيه بشكل لافت في
مهرجان كان السينمائي في دورته 66 حيث
تتوزع نحو خمسه عشره مشاركه في كل
المسابقات نصفها في المسابقات الرسميه
توزعت سبعه افلام عربيه على مسابقات
مهرجان كان السينما الدولي بدورته لهذا
العام حيث يشارك لاول مره في تاريخ
المهرجان الفيلم السوداني وداعا جوليا
للمخرج محمد كردفاني تدور احداث الفيلم في
الخرطوم وقبيل انفصال الجنوب وينتمي الى
الدراما الاجتماعيه مع جانب تشويقيا بطابع
مستلهم من السينما الواقعيه
فيلم يمثل المغرب للمخرج اسماء المدير
يحمل عنوان كذب ابيض ويتحدث عن سيرتها
الذاتيه من خلال صوره تعثر عليها وهي مع
مجموعه اطفال في الدار البيضاء وتعود بها
ذكريات الى تفاصيل واحداث مرت بها وعن بعض
الاكاذيب التي سمعتها من جدتها لكنها كانت
اكاذي بيضاء هو بدا بصوره انا كل حكاياتي
التي حكيتها او ساحكيها تبدا من منطلق
صوره واحده هي بالصدفه لكن كذب ابيض ايضا
انطلق من سوره سوره قدمتها لوالدته عن
طفولتي
في المسابقه الرسميه بنات الفا للمخرج
كوثر بن هنيه ويعالج قصه حقيقيه عن اربع
بنات للام الفا يتم اغراؤهن للعمل مع
المنظمات الارهابيه وهو فيلم درامي وثائقي
فيلم مغربي اخر للمخرج كما الازرق كاشارك
في المسابقه الثانيه في المهرجان ويحمل
عنوان كلاب الصيد ويتحدث هذا الفيلم عن
حسن وعصام الابن والاب ويح
اليومي في احدى رواح الدار البيضاء
ويقومان باعمال خارج القانون لصالح هذا
المتنفذين ويحاولان ايجاد حل لمشكلتهما
جزء من المجتمع المغربي الذي لا يوجد حلول
ماديا
ويبحث عن
مشاريع خطيره كما سيعرض المهرجان فيلم
ببساطه مثل سيلفان للمخرج التونسيه
الكنديه منى شكري وهناك افلام اخرى خارج
المسابقه منها فيلم من الجزائر عمر
الفراوله ويروي الفيلم قصه الرجل عصابات
تجبره في الظروف على الفرار من فرنسا الى
وطنه الجزائر ويحكم عليه بالسجن لمده 20
عاما في الجزائر هذا العام الحضور العربي
في مهرجان كان هو الابرز سبعه افلام في
المسابقات الرسميه وشخصيات اخرى توزعت على
لجنه التحكيم سعد المسعودي العربيه مهرجان
كان السينمائي جنوب فرنسا
في نهايه النشره هذا تذكيرا بابرز
العناوين
السعوديه وامريكا تعلنني توقيع طرفي
الصراع في السودان اتفاقيه لوقف اطلاق
النار قصير الامد
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وخادم الحرمين
والعهد على السودان وعلى استقرار السودان
وعلى امن السودان السعوديه تشدد حرصها على
امن واستقرار السودان وسط ترحيبا باتفاق
وقف اطلاق النار
لن يعلنوا بسط السيطره على بخموت بعد
باجمر وكياب تؤكد استمرار المعارك في
المدينه
شكرا جزيلا مشاهدينا على حسن المتابعه
اعود والقاكم على راس ساعه المقبله شكرا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات